[Music]
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey bab
hey bab hey bab heyab it's Thursday and
you know what that means everyone loves
hey babes now scissor
man
hey babe
hey look at that do The champ is here I
I honestly think that that should just
be the intro and we don't ever have to
sing songs anymore I was going to say do
you want to actually move on and evolve
this show from the songs to that is it
yeah let's do it it's getting harder and
harder for us anyway we're running out
of songs I love that you do you mind
play we'll play at the top of every
episode from now on goad come on we get
a Bowen inro dude I know you felt this
already but the heaviness the weight of
this unbel unbeliev do you own belts s
like I was going to I was going to turn
before I answered and say I want you to
guess if I owned it'sing question loaded
I do own I do own belts my most recent
belt purchase was the white
InterContinental uh WWE belt but that
was that was years ago I haven't bought
a belt in a while and I have news for
you we don't talk about that here that's
right well I got news for you I got news
for you I'm going to make another
purchase yeah I am cuz this is for sale
actually this is actually for sale this
is a customized belt now correct me if
I'm wrong that is the real belt that is
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars that cost $4,000 to make to make
what American or Canadian American hard
make now that exact belt not a replica
that exact belt that he wears they made
10 of them for sale and they're on sale
right now there's like a half of them
left now are you going to get one I
don't know if I'm going to buy it at
that price point just because it is the
it it is you know like a used keia of
Sportage do you get any of the money on
the Belt I get yeah yeah absolutely oh I
didn't know that well I'll just give you
like I'll just hand you some money later
yeah can we venmo you and you get us a
belt wait s can I put this on you yeah
please I I strap it on if it even fits
me yes that's what we normally do um
hold on hold on I mean I could help I'm
getting yeah let me get so I will buy
the replica version of this for
sure you got it on I don't know but it I
Feel Like A Champion there it is it look
okay so now so now here you go it's on
it's on I'm I'm even wearing this it's
on and you feel it and do you remember
that's it Daddy asked this is what this
is the weight you were carrying around
before you started Factor before you
started eating Factor meals this is what
it was you were wearing championship
belt you were wearing a tag team
championship belt of weight that's it
dude I got to be honest I got to be
honest with you it's a look it's a look
you if you came in if you came in with
this is the look
go
goe this is
great oh hey s you doing wow oh wow hey
dude you look I have to put on you got a
haircut that's all it is huh it looks
fantastic you look thin you look you if
I'm going to be honest with you
you look
like and I'm
and listen you you literally and this is
this is the utmost compliment what's up
you look like a gay black man thank you
so
much I mean I I feel like I I own this
though not not only like it's m now I
just mean like I feel like I I'm I'm
wearing the belt the belt's not wearing
me exactly sure sure you should be more
specific first CU you know sometimes
people the T they're not wearing tattoos
the tattoos are wearing them yeah you're
that belt is a part of you I think it
should be fashion you're part of your
fashion I win this if I win this belt
I'm you I'm going to the Del the store
like this I'm going to the bank like
this let it be known I'm not taking I'm
coming to the bank I'm making a deposit
and everyone's going to take note
because I'm I'm wearing this to the
movies I'm wearing this to every I'm
wearing to the I'm wear it to the gym I
don't take this off I would shower with
this I would take off my shirt take off
my pants and I have you done it I have
not show the Lea Le I would put like a
nice leather uh protectant on it and
then I would take a nice hot shower with
it on I'll tell you what I'm not going
to take that off for airport security
nah no way dude well they take it out
every time no way every cuz there's so
much metal they think I don't know what
they think it is what do you have to do
you have to explain yourself I have to
stand there and then everyone stares at
me and then they're like w I'm the
Champion can I
every time so I have to always fact when
I win a title I have to factor in an
extra maybe 15 minutes to go through
security just to wait for the bag and
the belt to be checked what can but it
feels it feels it feels like it like I
you know honestly dude you look like you
look like what a wrestler is supposed to
look like to me you got the you you got
the vibe you got the energy I I buy this
well he routed off a list of great
gimmicks that he can do and I'm I'm a
fan of all of them the TSA guy yeah Joe
gave me [__] this yeah what would sound
did we discuss what like your move would
be did you guys discuss that already I
had written up some fake some characters
and one was the t a TSA guy that okay
that would be your wrestling his well
his finishing move was the full body
cavity search right you know sort of
like that we we we we we ruminated on
this in the last one I like that but uh
I'm just going to if you don't mind
absolutely I'm just going to sit with it
for a
little let me ask you a question Anthony
how are your how are your feet my feet
do you have Good Feet um are we talking
the aesthetic of the feet or how how
they feel healthwise take take me
through take me through that's a
prescription you know you're I honestly
feel like I'm seeing better is this okay
what do you think about this for me it
look it looks it looks like
you shot JFK or
something maybe I
did yeah I I honestly I I feel like I
can see but why aren't they going behind
your ears I have a very setback ear okay
I glasses don't really fit me too well
because my ears are very set so what do
you do about that I have to get
custommade glasses with very long arms
because my ears are set too far in the
back of my head have you thought about
plastic surgery for my ears to get to
move my ear up shift them forward I've
never thought about it I've never
thought about it but if they for me I
would only get a surgery if my life
depended on it if the doctor say if you
move your ears up you'll get another 5
years and I would move my ears up I
would do it I to be fair I never noticed
they were set back and yeah oh yeah look
see that this is a problem a lot of
times glances go like this on me because
actually one of my ears is closer to my
eyes than the other I have my ears are a
little off-kilter as they say okay now
back to my feet do you have because I
always want because I've been dealing
with a heel injury that's why I'm
wearing sneakers like this you see I'm
wearing chunky sneakers see these chunky
sneaks oh yeah those are those are
fashionable but people are on the fence
about them even in my family they're on
the fence I haven't seen those you like
those I like those I like those and I
like those on you I like that so people
are people are on the fence about these
chunky shoe chunky chunky shoe look I'm
wearing chunks yeah chunky shoes are in
chunky shoes are in you know either men
with heel problems or girls in the Soho
House they wear chunky shoes right and I
have a heel issue an Achilles heel issue
and it's so um it's so like demoralizing
of an injury to deal with a heal injury
cuz it just no matter what you do it
hurts so have you ever had to deal with
a foot injury and what did you do for it
um a foot injury only went off the top
of my head was the first night I've ever
trained for wrestling and a ring post
fell on it and I thought I broke it and
then I had train for three hours with a
no way it was just ballooned up so I
just iced it and I kept wrestling though
what's an injury that you've dealt
with uh tore my miniscus tore my MCL and
meniscus uh bruised nerves in my back
tooth kicked through my lip tooth kick
through your lip I got drop kicked in my
serious went anything serious I mean it
was a KNE
surgery um but uh that's crazy man
that's off the top of my head probably
you know a baseball player yeah oh yeah
okay yeah didn't you did you play
baseball I know you played basketball I
played I played baseball in sixth grade
sixth to e8th grade C shout out coach
Charlene too I had a female coach in
sixth to eth grade a female baseball
coach yeah I had a female basketball
coach really yeah back in in the 90s 89
which is unheard of back then that's
Progressive for well nobody wanted to
coach us my
friend lesie was that possible lesbian
no it's my friend's mother really so
possible
lesbian possible Les what we talking
about that is that the name of the
episode possible
lesbian how accurate do you think you
could be on guessing lesbian yes I think
lesbian is much easier to guess than gay
man you do I think I think I can sniff
out a lesbian I I I well because well
okay not by you mean like a good
oldfashioned like when we were growing
up like a you know just
a a woman who really can take care of
herself like for example my gym teacher
my gym teacher in grammar school we knew
she was a lesbian cuz she looked like
Liu Kang from Mortal Kombat and we would
she would turn
around
and she would turn around and we would
go and we would go
lukang that's what she look like yeah
that one go up a little bit pippy right
there in the MD right there that one she
had hair like Liu
Kang so she was a Les
Les allegedly allegedly allegedly yes
got oh that's when you're not quite sure
that's when you're not quite sure
a send us people in your life who are
azarly send it to hey bab potage Gmail
or no press sh we do a segment we should
do an Lesly segment Let's do an Lesly
segment we bring up I mean look anyone
could be gay anyone could be straight
it's not like that but cuz you we'll get
some curveballs you know 100% yeah many
people think why don't we have the fans
email most people think I am actually is
it no press Network gmail.com really is
that what it is I think CU we posted my
whole career in public I think it's no
press Network gmail.com this is a new
segment that we'll play here on hey babe
here hold on I think she sent it uh hold
on
venor okay so email possible lesbians to
no press Network gmail.com and each week
we're going to we're going to take a
shot at allegedly the game where we
guess if they're a lesbian or
not send them in and ventia and homeless
pimp and the rest of the great Anthony
cos signs it's SOI yeah um no I do have
a good Gar though it does hurt well
actually no I don't what is the lesbian
G radar it's a Sil gatar yeah gar what
am I saying so um I think I do too uh
did it hurt you are you good no I just I
thought that I saw better with them but
when I've taken them off I realized I
see better without them okay just like
when I wear sunglasses like when I wear
sunglasses when I'm driving I don't
really feel like I'm connected I don't
feel like I'm when I take them off I
feel like the whole world has opened up
for me when I have them on it's I don't
like the shade darkness of it yeah if
fact to really see something like in a
dress I take them off you know when you
lower the radio to see in a dress yes I
I do the same thing with sunglasses can
you put those back on for one second if
I walked into the doctor's office and
you were the doctor and you were wearing
those I would immediately walk back out
because my ears are two back something
suspect about it because of the GL
because it might be the size of my
glasses on you but something right now
screams to me something's a little off
maybe not trust yeah I kind of like him
though yeah you like that I I kind of
like them right what do you think of my
sneakers are they too chunky no I'm not
a big New Balance fan so that's probably
the only thing I don't like but
otherwise I like them okay SE a lot
especially in Los Angeles has a lot of
chunky shoes and a lot of different
styles so I'm I was getting abused by my
family uh yesterday and today because of
my because of the Chun alone what are
they saying about it they were just
saying you know you know Jasmine was
saying oh my God you look so white I was
like since when is has this been an
issue she kept saying you look so white
you look like a nerdy white guy she was
like you look like your father and she
said you look like you're wearing high
heels and I said honestly I feel like
I'm wearing high heels and I like that
it's only because they're New Balance
that's what I feel like new balance is a
very white I think they're associated
with something like that I mean I I I
have I'm a sneaker guy so I have tons of
sneakers I have my share New Balances I
don't have that I have you like these
though you would consider these in the
store cuz right now I'm getting to a
stage where it's com a comfort over I
don't give a [__] so so I put those
things on and they make my feet feel
like uh you know like I'm on a cloud or
like I'm 30 years younger I'll wear
those things I don't care what they look
like but but you did pick those out
alone I did you were alone what I will
tell you though about these is I've been
wearing them pretty consistently for the
last 48 hours my heel pain has went from
an 8 out of 10 to about a 5 out of 10
the way you walk in a shoe like this
type of shoe this New Balance shoe
because it's a bit elevated and has arch
support that it's it's everything if you
have a you got to get a Dr scholes foot
insert and put it in your sneaker if
you're not going to get Chunky New
Balances to align your foot wow because
that will destroy your foot that's so I
want to pick one up I want to pick a
pair up do they have any that don't look
like two
snowmobiles that's the
issue that's the issue win's coming up
though Chris and you're good yes well
that's the thing the the grip I have on
steps I will never fall down the stairs
with these and I've been known to fall
down the stairs weekly I will never fall
down the stairs with these they grip on
the it's a hiking shoe this is a hiking
shoe I'm sold yeah these are Express
jeans and this is Zara shirt I actually
these are Zara shoes I fit 363 and and I
also went on a I went on a spree from
Zara BL it out unless they want a
sponsor um oh they a sponsor no I'm
saying blur it out unless they want a
sponsor right these are from Zara Z see
wow see that's the thing nowadays you
know I've also gotten to the point I
think all three of us are in the same
room I've pimp to all four of us is that
we I am now over the fact like it
doesn't need to be designer or name
brand I just want it to be comfortable
and I want to like the way it looks I
don't care anymore if it's the latest
Jordan one I don't care at all like I'll
get a sneaker from Zara no problem I'll
wear I I almost picked up a pair of
shoes you know where my my daughter had
get you know you go Catholic school
shopping for the shoes and they have
like right stri I not stri no the um oh
the place on Richmond Terrace yes that
we went to as kids yes oh what that's
still there that's still there so my
kids gets their shoes you get the
uniform shoes you get the uniform shoes
I almost picked myself up a pair of
uniform shoes that would be really funny
just because they were comfortable those
grammar school Catholic uniform shoes
yeah because the guy said you you you
won't imagine you won't believe how
comfortable they are I said let me see
and then I put them on and it literally
feels like you don't even have a foot it
feels like you're just like like it's
perfect
stubs it feels did you put your foot in
that like silver like measuring device I
haven't done that since I'm in Grammar
School bro how about a new balance they
do it they do it digitally now they take
like a 3D scan of your foot they will
not only if you go to New Balance store
the one in the flat iron District you
put your foot in a machine does it not
only does it measure your foot and show
you a digital composite of your foot it
tells you what New Balance shoe is best
for your foot oh that sounds like a
genius that sounds like the whole AI
thing I don't want AI of my feet
seriously bance yeah well now they got
your feet your Fe your feet are out
there now what do you think of the
Mexican alien oh God did you guys about
on T what do you think of that is it
cake they showed it they show no but
they but then there's a Mexican alien
cake that somebody made yeah I thought
it that was the same thing no no no no
no they were Mak that was a joke I
thought that was a bogus picture and it
turned out to be a cake no no no no no
somebody made a cake no they baked the
cake to show how easy it was to
replicate that oh no but I did see that
like you know when you something gets
like twe tweeted and underneath it like
people like will rebut it and they tag
onto it right was it cake no they they
made this cake quick because to make
cakes like that you just got to get a
digital 3D like printer and then you can
make it so they just got a picture and
made up but no The Mexican government
for Real's oh went the thing is but I
saw I thought that was a hoax no the
president of Mexico that was the
Presidente pimp wasn't that Presidente I
I thought I read that people refuted it
and it was a hoax if it's not clear my
afternoon what yeah but what about but
isn't this El Presidente of Mexico who
came out here oh Mexican Congress
Mexican Congress I haven't heard a
followup but everyone's [__] on it
what about the alien guy Jeremy uh the
guy from Limp Biscuit what's it no not
from Lim biscuit from Blink
182 what's he from what about blink2 the
lead singer or is he the lead singer
pimp or one of the guys from
blink is one of the leading alien
experts like literally gets tapped by
the US government like he is our guy wa
am making
singer am I making this up that sounds
like a h no yeah like he's stepped up
into a fox molder position I'm not
making this up no for real Google it no
no no no no Google
it the lead singer of the lead singer2
was our leading alien expert name Tom
Holland not Tom Holland really Jeremy
corbel no no it's Google uh Blink 182
Blink 182 Tom aliens Tom right turns
aliens Hunter this is a shame I should
know this Tom Del became a UFO
researcher New York Times so they're not
making it up dude it's real and what did
he say I want to know what he said about
it he said sorry I are
wrong Sor to tell you United era you
talking UAP yeah you know me oh wait
what so he doesn't do Blink 182 no dude
he's all in on Aliens and if he said
it's right and and dude the Mexican
Congress if they they said their bodies
are a thousand years old and the wild
thing is is they're saying what the new
kind of theory is is it's not that
aliens are in these far away planets
it's not that it's that they're in other
dimensions so that they can appear and
reappear because they it's all about
interdimensional stuff not like it's a
million years away so that means they
live just amongst us immediately exactly
they could be living see this is what
they had and they were little a thousand
years old and they had three fingers
wait hold on H that's what all the small
things was about the little thanks yeah
there you go there you go little
aliens oh
man right welcome to mexic are aliens I
got a lot to say okay I got a lot to say
first of all these are okay these are
two of the most prized possessions that
are in our physical human existence okay
it's two alien life forms that are also
1,000 years old they had to be probably
protected and kept in a certain way
right you tell me they just wheeled them
out in two open boxes and propped them
up for people to see what about the air
what about the light like these things
are from another planet and a thousand
years old they put them in filing
cabinets that they found on the sixth
floor that's that's literally that's
literally like the freaking Container
Store look look at that that's real all
right you don't think it's real another
thing they're identical and they're only
that tall and are they Exum like have
they been embalmed like or they are
they're very stiff supposedly allegedly
allegedly they mummified themselves
somehow through their ancient alien
technology and it makes sense if they're
a thousand years old because this
correlates with all the ancient findings
with the p that means they could die
here wait you go back up pimpy these are
not mummies these are complete bodies
that have not been manipulated this is
guy speaking under oath they were found
in Peru in 2017 are estimated to be a
thousand years old one of the bodies was
pregnant one of the bodies out there
fing no one of those aliens was pregnant
Tracy Morgan you
pregnant quip okay babe let me tell you
something brushing and flossing have
gotten so much easier for me I use quip
now okay I'm done with my old toothbrush
I use an electric toothbrush and quip is
the way to go dude quip first of all I
love the way it feels on my teeth it's
like a nice massage for my teeth for my
gums they deliver all the oil care
Essentials right to your they it's like
they're delivering them right into my
mouth it really is I got gum mints I got
uh toothpaste in them I got the travel
brush the new one well I'd use it for
travel I should say at home I have a
clunky clunky thing that I'm replacing
now with quip and the thing is I never
took that clunky one on the road with me
right because it's clunky right but quip
is like a regular toothbrush that also
have Al all the benefits of like an
electric it's a dude call me call me Qui
vanwinkle yeah I literally they have $7
replacement floss tips shipped to you
every 3 months to keep things flowing
smoothly and prevent mineral deposits
from building up sleek and slim enough
to keep your countertops as clean as
your teeth easy to control water flow
that leaves you feeling squeaky clean
but only use it on your teeth folks
you'll be tempted to you it elsewhere
but it's only for your mouth the quip
electric toothbrush is loved by over 9
million mouths that's a lot of mouths
absolutely so if you go to get quip.com
heyab right now you'll get 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser that's your
20% off any electric toothbrush mint and
gum dispenser or water flosser and
getquip.com
heyab sorry atg getquip.com that's GE
tqip p.com heyab quip the good habits
company love it s I want to talk you
about German engineered blades that get
delivered right to your door you know
I'm talking about H I'm not talk I'm
talking about blades for your face folks
okay if you want a nice shave okay
listen and there's a subscription for
everything these days right including
shaving you can get beef jerky
subscription why not get subscriptions
for your face okay with Harries you get
high quality blades right to your door
this is what most guys are using it's
awesome they have a trial they have a
smooth shave a smooth shave should not
be rough from your wallet it really just
shouldn't be a rough from your wallet
sometimes it is I agree with you and
that's the whole point of this thing
right it's convenience and saving money
I I have Harry's I use Harry's that's my
blade okay really yeah I have a
beautiful orange blade that has a nice
little bit of weight to it and uh handle
and and I I it's it's a closest shave
one of the closest shaves I've ever
gotten right and I I actually like their
foaming um shaving cream as I love it
I'm foaming out the M I love the scent
of it creams washes lotions they keep
your skin healthy hydrated blades made
in their own Factory in Germany that
stay sharp they are Sleek ergonomic
weighted handles that look right in your
bathroom and give you precise control
with each swipe the highest customer
satisfaction in the Shaving industry
Peeps and you can cancel the
subscription any time it's a no-risk
trial so get a subscription that saves
you time and money with Harry's get
started with a $13 trial set for just $3
at harry's.com
that's Harry's H RR
y.com for a $3 trial set love it so it's
real that's the thing and I think the
media I think the media is is choosing
to not make this a big deal Mexican
alien Mexican alien Trump's like build a
dome build
that country's full of alien always
happen now they're coming from other now
they're coming from the skies great
Trump impression both us I've never done
one moment that was my first time ever
just yeah wait so this is the second
alien thing cuz there was the one in
Vegas where the cop caught the on his
body cam it caught a streak coming from
the sky yeah that's where the kids saw
it and so he froze and there was a
circle in the yard oh we went in heavy
on that one oh yeah we girl we went in
we this is this is crazy because
if they got here you would think that
they're more Progressive than than us
but like I just didn't think they would
look like little ETS but they're a
thousand years old and here's here's
here's where it runs deep here's where
the conspiracy runs deep no but here's
where the conspiracy runs deep is that
they're saying that this
interdimensional stuff and they reason
because everyone's saying well it looks
like ET and they're saying that
Hollywood is like a CIA is like part of
the CIA like the the top Hollywood
people it's all intertwined so what they
do is in order to get it palatable for
the American public or the world public
what they'll do is they'll make movies
about things and start to desensitize us
for years and years and years until boom
they drop it like I you know we're all
in our 30s right or and I told sorry no
sorry he's a tween so so we're we're
we're in our 30s to 60s
so so I I if you told us as a as if we
when we were 13 years old if you told
any of of us hey The Mexican government
is just announced that aliens are real
they had a press conference our minds
would be blown we would be running into
the streets there would actually be
chaos and rioting because we'd be like
oh my God I told my 13 I told my
13-year-old stepson about this he goes I
don't care I always knew they were
aliens because he's been desensitized my
8-year-old didn't care at all no it
would have been people running in the
streets but they've doing this on
purpose they slowly desensitizing it and
that's why the Hollywood is like they
slow it looks like ET because they saw
this already they knew this already the
government showed this to them and said
make a movie that makes it look like
that cuz we got that how did they get it
like what ship are they driving believe
him Tom Delong what's going on okay we
found 1,000-year-old twin Mexican aliens
that are 3 feet tall and exume
themselves and the person who's the
expert on it is the guy from literally
Tom dong Tom dong is is the leader he is
the leading alien expert they're going
to make him Secretary of Defense and
then Mike Chemical Romance is going to
be Secretary of the Treasury I love m I
support it in the new government I
also I love the photo that they used of
Tom where he's just it's a rockar photo
it's not him like professional in the in
the alien outfit no because because they
want to they want to discredit they want
to make it look crazy they want all this
to be like there's no way this is
happening because they eventually
they're just going to say yeah they're
here and then it's not nobody's going to
care because we're already you know
little sprinkles like right now if I
told you you know the government killed
JFK and I and they went out and proved
it you're day wouldn't change that much'
be like yeah I read 10 books that
probably said it's true so they'll do
things like that and I feel like we're
living in a time where they're just
going to or I mean listen Mexico is you
know you know it's a first world country
it is they have a ton of money Mexico is
not that different than us so they're
for their Congress to be like this is
legit but that's crazy so were they
doing what essentially happened at the
hearing that we had a few months ago but
like what so what was their endgame just
to be like hey will we want to join the
conversation we also or were they like
can somebody help us out here like what
is this exactly I think that they just
wanted to put their government decided
you know what we're going to we're just
going to put the information out there I
mean this I mean if that's proved if
that's discredited that is a huge hit to
the Mexican Government no yeah no I mean
that's real that but nobody but they
they they wanted to nobody cares they
that thing has three fingers how do they
know it's
pregnant they found C dripping at
that doesn't even prove anything they
found hey bab dripping out of it you
gotta be
that but they put they found hay bab
dripping out of
it alien hay bab Al imagine the aliens
are working with the cartel oh my God I
don't I'll believe anything now that's
the whole that's actually going to be
the downfall of society we just I we
don't know what to believe it not and
and the craziest things are true so I
just said it the Le BL too it's the
government's Authority dude it it it is
it's one of those things what's this now
this was the crazier UFO UFO story we
lost one of our fighter jets and it's an
autopilot Somewhere Over Us airspace
what where's the fighter the F35 was
left in a zombie State the uh oh he had
to eject but the the plane on AI is just
flying around right now yeah oh right
now yeah as of yesterday it's been lost
for
wait there's no pilot in that nope wait
where to shoot it down they've lost it
they don't know where it is how do you
lose it though don't they track these
things I don't know maybe they didn't
put comes crashing through our studio
right
now dude there's no pilot in that he hit
look at this right okay so we got two so
okay one of the most sophisticated jets
in the world is missing as officials
believ the F-35 was left in his zomie
state after the pilot was forced to
eject here's what we know Two fighter
jets were flying side by side when the
incident took place for unknown reasons
the Jet's transponder isn't working the
incident took place over North
Charleston the Jet's range is 1200 miles
however it's not known how much fuel was
in the jet at the time of the ejection
the search for the jet is now focused on
Lake mol Tre which is about 50 miles
from North Charleston 50 miles that
thing he's going a th000 miles an hour
well it's swirling there it keeps
turning is it just going in a circle I
think it's running on like AI autopilot
I'm not sure what it's doing that's not
good for our government like you were
supposed to be the most mighty military
I feel like I feel like Isis is looking
at like these these losers look J I mean
literally like someone was like oops
like how does that even happen yeah how
does it even happen they were flying
side by side we have an unpiloted
fighter jet that we can't catch on our
own that's operating have you ever seen
anything like that it's on AI imagine
the AI
turns right you know that could happen
with our no you know that could happen
with our cars when you're driving a car
when you're driving your car a plane
anything at any moment somebody could
hij Jack that just get into that and
then control that I told you I had a c I
told you about this the CIA agent that
came on Chrissy chaos said the only
thing that scares him that keeps them up
tonight it's not World War III it's not
nuclear terrorism it's none of that
those stuff us has so much defense it's
hacking in to the to our systems and
like what happened did you see that this
is the two major Las Vegas casinos
reeling following major ransomware
attacks this is where a CIA agent told
me this is the thing that we are
defenseless against if anybody at any
time
you that's where they're going to get
you and they could knock out the power
grid and send us back to the Stone Age
and then he said by the time we got the
power up and running you'd probably have
a 100 million America 100 million people
worldwide dead because of just you can't
function right I mean I'd kill myself
not having know Instagram yeah yeah the
elevators were even shut off that's
scary and the rooms like are all
electronic you're just kind of caught in
it right no yeah nothing works in Vegas
yeah and apparently I'll be there
September 30th
Cosmo tickets are not selling apparently
anyone who swiped their card at Caesars
had their identity stolen and they ran
up credit card bills on people who just
happen to stay there immediately yeah
and uh but if you've ever stayed at one
or like that weekend I don't know and
previously Caesar's apparently paid off
the hackers quietly so this is like a
second or third oh cuz they held them no
way that ain't right and then they came
back there's got to be some type of code
of ethics here no no I'm dead serious
you if you you if you you know hold me
for hold that for ransom you get paid
you can't come back otherwise no one's
ever going to pay the ransom again
seriously I'm not going to pay that
Ransom again you never Ransom me once
shame on me shame on you Ransom me twice
no way bro no way shut it down Mike shut
it down it is true I am I am so scared
of it that I have thought about taking
every dollar I have out of the bank and
just literally putting it in like like
fireproof suitcases and hiding it
somewhere
really I'm not even joking around like
like you just want to put cash in your
walls no not in my walls and even if I
did I wouldn't say that here crypto
that's where you got to go crypto not
not in my walls or anything but I I'm
I'm not making a joke though I've
thought about it like do you think one
occasion I've thought about it like
digitally you could be attacked and
right insured though up to a certain I
don't know what the numberers what if
what if they hit a button and deletes
everybody they're going to Ure us all
yeah cuz that's the truth the money in
our bank account isn't really backed up
by any gold none of it's real it's just
numbers I was hacked once my debit card
whated they took three grand from me at
somewhere in Puerto Rico and then I had
to go through the bank and had them they
refunded me and they got the money back
for interesting I I've been I mean I've
had those Puerto Ricans they're
tricky I have a family of them I mean
you have to see the shenanigans they get
they get me involved
in those Puerto Rican
programmers um imagine it was my
daughter did you steal money from
Anthony like I gave it back dad I yeah I
don't trust anything dude have you guys
seen the new like viral rapper who's
teaching kids how to do debit card
schemes over his song that's going
apparently it's very very simple for
these kids okay no do we have I thought
you about to drop that beat do we have
audio over this I mean you want to check
it out it's it's crazy yeah I want to be
because you know too like with our
justice system right now like you just
can't go to like if you commit a crime
they just don't arrest you and if they
do arrest you just get out you have to
like really like murder someone anything
else is like one of my neighbors said
that um their nephew stole stole a city
bike stole a city bike from someone like
pushed them off stole it went into a
store what yeah I don't know you could
have just got one I don't know why
pushed them off stole it got on the city
bike or the not the city bike the um
what are the ones like the bird no but
but the ones that you do pimp not you
don't pedal it the electric the electric
bike stole an electric bike went into a
grocery store like beat up the clerk
like bashed his head took the money they
found him the cops found them arrested
him he was out in 24 hours out with just
like a desk appearance ticket CU he only
stole 200 bucks and anything you have to
steal over $1,000 for it to be gr larsy
anything under is petty larsy and they
don't care about you stealing the I was
like Jesus [__] it's it's rough out
there got go back I don't want to go I
don't want to go back all school like
you know you know beheading people but I
would like in a situation like that no
in a situation like that a little bit
like tar and feather someone yeah a I
don't want to kill anyone but we jump we
dump tar on you and we put feathers on
you and then you're screwed for months
you're screwed mon back in colonial
times that's what would make people stop
in their tracks I don't want to get
tarred and feathered so I think bring
back tar and Feathering is an option I
get that I for theft specifically for
theft in any type of like if you're not
going to get executed or put in prison
at least get tar and
feathered you know I mean it's just an
option who after this Google tar and
Feathering it is a tar hot hot T it
could kill you it could okay so so
there's an element of pain I don't want
to kill anyone I don't want to kill
anyone it's not just inconvenience it's
an element of pain cuz it's hot yes yes
but you know you could walk that off
scolded but then it's drying on you yeah
and and they didn't have gooone back
then no can you Google FEA for life
after this what's that are you feathered
for life like like here here's taring
and Feathering so yeah see somebody like
that you this guy got German American
John Ms got tarred and feathered during
World War I for not supporting War Bond
drives you got to support
those see go Google like put images like
Colonial tar and feather put Colonial or
yeah here we go see these guys would get
tarred and feathered they did it big in
the American Revolution and the French
Revolution those are paintings though
yeah but I'm saying Jesus Christ it was
back in the day but yeah that guy see
had the scars and the feathers on him
for life so you know I just think that
that's something yeah I mean it's almost
like now when you when you take
something and the blue dye explodes on
you it's like our version of be you know
what they should do now that' be funny
if they it just exploded with tar and
Feathers yeah just right in the
store trying to walk out like a
windbreaker then they just let you go
yeah because you're walking out like a
like a like a chicken yeah oh here we go
let's do this famous scammer
Tommy
G how to write a dump ladies and
gentlemen I'm Tommy G today we're diving
in the world of scamming everything
you're about to see is purely
reenactment and for educational purposes
only PA that one second why would people
make a certain amount of money like I
guess like let's call it a five foot
stack right or whatever that was why do
they start one small Mexican alien size
stack why when they get to that level of
money do they immediately start dressing
like a [__] [__] I know I know what
is why do they start wearing chairs on
the head 15 chains a jacket that
literally looks like you're a like it's
just it's is that fashion he's wearing a
bulletproof vest but it's a jacket
exactly I mean that might be very
fashion forward it's not for me the ski
goggles on the side of his head it's a
lot of work just to put on those three
bracelets
okay he literally sat on his laptop in
the car did some kind of scam and goes
right into the bank and gets somebody
else's
$110,000 to and he raps about it and
teaches kids how to do it how is he it's
like
day why do you think scamming become so
popular what do you guys think when kids
look up to you it's actually pretty
crazy you want work for 50 years to back
broke and now you can finally do what
you want cuz you finally got some money
how long you guys want to be in the game
for year I want to be like probably 30
than invest whatever [__] 30 then invest
okay at least he's thinking about the
future 30 and then I 30 then I'll give
it to other criminals yeah he opens up a
Vanguard yeah this can't be real though
it can't be real let me sniff it to make
sure and they're by the way they're
outside the bank on camera literally
just like like like holding it up to
camera and being like I got this fore
it's still there he just walked out
we're gonna you a gas St wait so he he
does
a different crime a different con each
time and then makes a song about it to
teach him he'll teach people how to do
credit card he's wearing ski goggles
upside down and backwards and he has a
gold thing hanging over his neck that is
a full human hand holding a credit card
machine he's got the face from V for
Vendetta yeah he's like a a modern-day
like ghetto Barney you know he's got the
kiss he sings it doesn't it doesn't make
teaches the kids but I couldn't bring it
on the plane with me so how much does
this cost can't be no more than like 100
and how much do this major like over
500k so if someone says they're a
certified dumper this is what they're
talking about they could either be the
person getting the dumps with the
skimmer or they could be the person
riding them up using them say like I
know somebody working at McDonald's
right I'll give them a skimmer and they
work through drivethru to say somebody's
buying something right now right they'll
pay right and then my person will
quickly go like
this do matter guilt day I have like a
list of like 20 of them about wipe
this didn't know there was an option is
the FBI looking into you cuz how are you
not in federal prison at this point I
know what I'm doing you got a VPN a
proxy server RDP and the way someone
stops this is by lock their bank account
right
yeah so as far as scamming goes are you
feel like your NBA level is some scammer
oh I'm I'm like LeBron of a scammer and
Michael Jordan combined does your mother
know scammer no I tell her I do crypto
so now I got the number I don't get it
what did he do he swiped his at the same
time
he has somebody working at McDonald's
drive-thru who has a skimmer device that
goes to his computer and after they run
your order at McDonald's They swipe it
there sends it to his laptop he swipes
it on a BL card got it so there's
someone at McDonald's that's hiding a
skimmer underneath the camera it's so
nice to have magic spoon back everybody
and I know uh that I am a fan because
cereal uh is one of my favorite things
to eat it's probably one of my top two
favorite breakfast things if you're a
Serial person like me you love magic
spoon because the cereal that we used to
love and eat as kids nostalgic as it may
be is just really bad to put in your
body and Magic spoon is basically they
reinvented your favorite childhood
cereals to taste great but each serving
contains zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and four to five neck
carbs per serving okay honey enough
flavor contains 1 gram of sugar that's
that's the big thing it's keto friendly
it's gluten-free it's grain free it's
soy free okay okay it's that I mean
that's the way to relive those moments
while you're watching your favorite
cartoons with magic spoon it's only 140
calories per serving this is like why
did it take so long for something like
this to come out okay magic spoon took
the Magic in their cereal and
transformed it into the on Theo snack
which I swear to God I opened my cabinet
this morning and we had two boxes of
that stuff and I think my girlfriend
bought it without even realizing that
they are uh uh they probably send me
some product actually so uh what was it
is they have these brand new treats and
you you know they're high protein cereal
bars for breakfast dessert and any time
in between they're just like marshmallow
treats that you had as a kid but with
only one gram of sugar 1 to two grams of
neck carbs they're packed with 11 grams
of protein parb bar the treats come in
two flavors I have both marshmallow and
chocolatey peanut butter whether you
like well whether you like sticking to
the class or trying something new there
a flavor that you'll love head to
magico to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try the magic for yourself and don't
forget to add their brand new
marshmallow and chocolatey peanut butter
treats be sure to use our promo code hey
babe at checkout to save $5 off your
order and Magic moon is so confident in
their product it's back with a 100%
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason that will fund your
money no questions ask remember get your
next delicious bowl of cereal at
magicpay bab to save $5 off thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring the episode
what's up everybody I am coming to the
Brea Improv I will be there October 13
1415 outside Los Angeles we got a
Thursday we got a Friday Saturday Sunday
shows Christy comedy.com for Ticky
wikies then October 18th Lista Nevada
the 19th Kansas City the 20th St Louis
the 21st Hammond Indiana and then
October 26th to the 28th Raleigh North
Carolina the capital all tickets at
Chris DC comedy.com for the love of God
buy a goddamn ticket what's up guys real
quick tour dates are on sale right now
at salcano comedy.com uh there's tons of
cities up there tomorrow night if you're
watching us right now on hey bab
tomorrow night I am in Bowling Green
Kentucky on Friday Cincinnati on
Saturday and Toledo on Sunday there's
still some tickets available so get
those uh following that we're going to
be in wils Bear Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware then we're doing mon
Savannah and Athens Georgia and so on
and so forth there's a big Illinois run
in November leading up to my comedy
special at the Vic in Chicago on
December 1st and 2nd the second sold out
as you guys I hopefully know uh and so
we edit two shows on the first all will
be taped and all if you have a ticket to
any of those shows you'll be eligible to
win uh a flight hotel and trip to the
set of impr practical jokers I'm
choosing one ticket out of those four
shows uh December 1st is still on sale
right now but it's going fast savano
comedy.com hope to see you guys on the
road I think that the reason a big
reason why they do this is because again
there what is really the penalty let's
say they get caught they're making all
this money what are they going to get a
few days in prison I heard of a scam I
have a friend he cop he told me told us
he did they did like a year sting this
guy was posing as a real estate agent
right and you would H like send me the
first month's rent and deposit and like
you think you're moving from Ohio you're
coming with all your stuff you move you
get to your place in New York and it
doesn't exist right but I but I stole
all your money he was doing that over
and over and over again they finally
caught him an undercover you know cop
caught him you know brought him in you
know like got got and then when he
showed up when the when the he told him
where to meet him or whatever they
arrested him and he was out of prison in
a day and because it was only offense he
there's no jail time so he made over the
course of two years like
$200,000 that's gone now that's crazy so
it's like so it's like I think these
kids do it cuz it's like what are you
going to like there is something I'm not
saying to do this but there is something
there is something just hear me out
there is something like where kids are
not going to do this in Afghanistan the
Taliban is not going to if the Taliban
finds out you're doing that you're going
to get killed and they're going to kill
your family in front of you get [__] and
feathered you're going to get [__] in
feather for real yeah so there is
something there is a little something
about where like I'm not saying I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that our
government should be like Taliban but
I'm just saying that if if you introduce
just a little like the hey bab if you
introduce a little if you introduce just
a little bit just one person gets made
an example I'm not saying all I'm not
maybe not this but I'm just saying you
bring out one person you say you did
this the other guy C you did this but
here's on do do you think they're so
Brazen because essentially in at the end
of the day they're stealing from uh
insurance company because that person is
going to report it as fraud and they're
going to be credited back that but I
think there's no penalty they're not
going to go to prison I think the big
thing is you're getting your freedom
taken away they're not that's not going
to happen to them
I I I I want to see this video that you
have up right now but it's actually
distracting me I was like you know what
scaming will take care of itself but uh
but I do want to say do you have that
guy's name and if you throw that name
into Google right now since that video
like I mean there's no way like you you
can't do the video and then just be like
no I'm just good I I just yeah wouldn't
the CIA and FBI or the FBI be like um
well now we have him immediately
yeah kind of want to follow this dude on
Tik Tok make some money yeah shut down
by he got shut down by YouTube he can't
monetize stuff anymore they're
interviewing the wire wire fraud
tutorial video wait arrested it said it
right there they're saying how isn't
punch made Dev in jail
yet
right he doesn't actually scam if he did
he'd be in jail he has a telegram which
is how he actually scams he sells
methods in which you pay him to learn
how to scam scam but he just scams you
in the end pretty smart cuz who's going
to tell the cops I got scammed by a guy
while trying to scam holy I'm actually
back in on this kid and I actually am
back I'm a fan actually I'm actually a
fan not only am I
in not only am I in but I'm going to
start emulating this
guy I I actually think it's actually
kind of cool what he does with his
fashion
yes that's crazy that's like the guy at
FedEx that opened the box took half my
marijuana and mailed me the other half
yeah because he knew I wouldn't call cuz
I can't you're already involved in a
crime
yeah I'm sorry just oh my God what we
got golf swing in somebody's butt I it
just you in a hat man I'm not a hat guy
it really makes me laugh dude I'm not a
hat guy you're not I'm trying
to so I'm trying to I'm trying to figure
out is it is it you don't normally wear
a hat so it's me adjusting to you in a
hat or that the Hat you need a very
specific hat I think I have a very
specific head as we've talked about
earlier my ears are too far set back and
I don't think I have a good hat head
yeah there's plastic surgery for that
too is there a plastic surgery to get
your head reshaped cran Cranium Sur I
mean you know cuz your hair is short
right now so you do look like a child
right oh that that that doesn't that
works backwards works but I can't be 39
with the hat like this sure you can yeah
you don't I don't know you need to not
the Tilt yeah the Tilt but put it
backward for a
second go back to the
Tilt I like the Tilt that for some
reason that looks that looks normal not
bad but every other way looks like you
need a
chaperon um oh back to the butt Che yeah
what is
this it's
oh that's the most fascinating thing
I've ever seen sick I had an inkling
that that was is what was going to
happen in the first one but I thought it
was just going to whip her in the ass I
was like there's no way she'll catch it
in those in those in that trunk there
you go and then when she did it again
and again three for three they really
that was a real roller coaster ride you
don't know those other cheeks are there
no the more this video Loops the
straighter I
get yeah but not for nothing you imagine
you there's a lot of pressure on that
last those last two chams got a lot of
pressure there dude cuz those other two
girls they take a drive a golf ball
drive to the hole at 3 feet away just
one Mexican alien's length away and they
they they go through that right now you
know what they're feeling like right now
they're just like please that third girl
man if she [__] up that's where the
term hole in one came from also not for
nothing but she's got a lot of pressure
on her too the one doing the drive oh
yeah she's off by even an inch to the
left or right she's she's form let me
ask form though look at that front I
don't know if it is good form I feel
like she's got good hands the legs are a
little rough let's just say this is this
but is this
CGI it might be I would I would like to
be what's as a as a gay man never wanted
a front row seat anything life what is
to the gay community to the gay male
Community what's the equivalent of boobs
cuz I know butts I'm sure you look at a
guy but like we look at a butt we a
woman has a butt and boobs what does the
guy have in place of boobs see one thing
that I've learned is everybody's uh
tastes are so different they all like
very very very different things
sometimes it's strange sometimes it's
pretty normal butts penises but then
there's like muscles but some people
like girth and like Bears it's there's
really I don't think there's no dead on
equivalent to titties I don't think so
like what can
you okay okay I just never thought about
that just got the breast is sexualized
whereas the female the male pectoral is
not necessarily sexualized in that way
it depends though CU I get many messages
that want to like rub my chest in my
arms and stuff chest is a chest of
course muscle worship oh yeah yeah oh
yeah no muscles I get but I didn't know
like it's you know you know always are
you a guy or a guy you don't know muscle
[Laughter]
worship dude thinking about you jacked
would be that would blow my mind like
you abs abolutely like [__] diesel like
if you had a body like Anthony I I don't
know that I would be able to handle
can't imagine I can't imagine it myself
I kind of want somebody Google noes
Network gmail.com I want you to put
Sal's head on Anthony's
Body I want you to send it to us in
addition to your Al uh what Ally Ally
allegedly uh photos that's a fun game I
think we should play Ally is a new
segment that I'm happy when it happens
naturally look at this idiot TSA agent
caught stealing money from passengers
luggage at Miami Airport what how do you
think what do you think is you know what
that means he must know that the the
camera is on not constantly monitored
only when there's an
incident because otherwise he wouldn't
do that he knows that there's a camera
there to be fair the dumbass left his
cash out in the bin it looks like he is
that what it what I'm seeing here yeah I
think he went into a pocket oh he's
doing it to more than
one right oh I look it looked like it
was like out what what what is the issue
like if you're going to be go through
the training and and hold a job that has
some type of uh authority to it I mean
how are you how are you then going to
turn around just steal out I lost faith
in the TSA I don't know if you remember
the cell we were walking through the
airport you and I I want to call I think
it was Columbus Ohio and there was a
female TSA agent that literally I think
it was Atlanta was Atlanta she was like
she had the phone in your face and she
was like yo say hello to my girlfriend
she was like you need to say hello to my
girlfriend and literally was standing
say hello to my girlfriend and I walked
through security without having any of
my bags check cuz she was distracted and
I just walked through and I was kind of
upset for him cuz I was like this got to
be so annoying she walk was that another
time then she no then she kept walking
with us escalator yeah and fully left
her post and I'm like seven people just
walked in cuz you wanted to make her
send a video to you her girlfriend and
I'm like what is this isn't real like
they they're not qualified I just had a
TSA agent hold up the line to come chase
after me to scissor me really I swear to
God well that I
get allow all the things night and then
I don't know these guys I don't think
they do their their job too well cuz
once I flew with a fullon kitchen knife
like a steak Knife I I was at my parents
house I had dinner on like one of the TV
trays and I guess my bag was open and it
fell directly into my my my carry on
wrestling bag I flew connecting flights
and all nothing I opened it up there's a
steak steak knife in there full steak
Knife did you just leave it in the hotel
you trying to bring it back I discarded
it right yeah I don't need a steak knife
on the way back holy [__] yeah see
that's scary yeah that is because it's
like you know but I think that I was
told by my friend who works for the
airlines that really like obviously
there's things like that that happen but
really if anything's going to God forbid
happen on a plane it's going to be in
from internal like you can go in like
the people that work for the airlines
like say the food people that put the
food on the plane they don't even go
through any security they come in to
like a back door and I'm between this
and the Mexican aliens I'm getting hard
pations I don't need you put putting
these seeds in my head we got to we got
to fly every goddamn weekend we got to
start driving I can't let's drive
everywhere Sacramento I'm coming I
thought about Ralphie maying it
seriously I thought about just getting a
bus like Nate does and just don't get on
a flight ber kryer Bert's bus I I went
on B I saw ber Cryer's bus C fantastic
beautiful yeah you just what you got to
do is just put all your dates at one
time right and then you then you could
justify you got to be away from the fan
first
wait you don't have a bus at all uh when
we do bus tours but in general I'm just
away like every other weekend but
sometimes I'll do like two three weeks
in a row and take a bus but I haven't
done that in quite a bit what's the
longest amount of time you've been away
from your house on your wrestling tour
uh this past seven weeks I was home for
maybe a day and a half combined no way
dude that's tough do you get like do you
ever like are you ever on the road like
feeling like you're going to cry cuz you
don't want to go do anymore do this
anymore not cuz you don't want to do
this anymore but you're like I can't
travel I I just want to be in one place
well he's also a young guy not with not
not a family and stuff you know I
started feeling that like you started
feeling that yeah that's true later in
life I I want to go out he aie piece of
[__]
yeah the only time it really starts
getting to me I mean I feel bad I leave
Michael alone because he's you know he's
well I mean he's busy but when I start
waking up in the hotel and I don't know
where I am I immediately just start
freaking out those are the scariest
moments for me I don't I mean I figured
out in like maybe 30 seconds but I'm
just like I get like heart palpitations
where the [__] am I I had that a lot
that's something you couldn't prepare
for like you had to train all those
years uh and go to school and stuff but
like you never really got a hint of this
kind of travel until you just start
right and then you just thrust into it
cuz like you you're thrust into it in a
way that even a comic isn't because our
our road stuff is a gradual build and
it's still not at the consistency in
which you perform which is sometimes a
few days a week every single week right
right Comics were pretty much gone on
the weekends and then that's it we're
home but you're gone for weeks without
coming home once like the the time I did
come home was uh we were in Chicago for
all out but I had to do a shoot and the
only way I could do it was if I flew
back to LA did the shoot and then hopped
right back on the plane back to Chicago
and then straight to like ID shoots yeah
so it was it was a brutal schedule it's
all back to normal now but it was pretty
[__] rough yeah but when you first
started you must have been like oh man
like this is I I didn't like this is
part of it huh well yeah I mean I kind
of expected it like our schedule isn't
as bad as WWE's at times but um that's
one of the better things about being at
aw2 is it's a little bit of a lighter
schedule we can kind of be home but
between Allin and and London and then
the pay-per-view being the following
week and then we have a third show
Collision so we're on and the acclaims
are on all of them really that's crazy
so it's it's a lot to manage but we're
figuring it out yeah shout out to the
Acclaim Champs got to have a lot of
energy to do this daddy s Max Caster
love Daddy s love you guys um everyone
loves the everyone everyone does love
the claim El does claim the other night
my daughter will wear my 8-year-old will
wear my shirts to bed like that's just
what she's comfortable in she just
doesn't have the job she wears my shirts
and she was wearing the scissor daddy
shirt to bed yes that this exact shirt
and then and then my you know Jasmine
her mom when she woke up in the morning
had breakfast like she was like is that
is this inappropriate I was like who
cares she's the [__] Tag Team champ
who cares
uh plugs but uh but make sure you watch
aw Dynamite Wednesday night on TBS at
8:00 p.m. aew Rampage 10 p.m. on Friday
nights TNT aew Collision Saturday nights
8:00 pm and make sure you follow me
Instagram and Twitter _ official Tik Tok
I'm new on it I don't know what the [__]
I'm doing but follow me at
bore official 37 there you go but that's
it don't get scammed SC thank you bud so
much great Happ appr wait should I end
this the same same way please take us
out so I have to ask Chris S please
throw your scissors in the air get ready
bab and I'm gonna throw my voice out and
not have it for the show on Wednesday
but scissor me Chrissy and
S that's dude that is second maybe only
to drinking a beer with stone cold I
swear to God that's pretty cool too love
it don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe